welcome back to peers working on
censored us Democrats are scrambling to
minimize the Fallout from a discovery of
classified documents of President
Biden's home and former office Leon
Panetta the former CIA Chief Tommy under
the Biden made a mistake so would it
harm Biden's re-election plans and does
it get Trump off the hook well joining
me now is the most watched woman in
cable news in America Fox News host and
Superstar Laura Ingram Laura your debut
on Piers Morgan uncensored I can't think
of anybody better to be on the show than
someone as unscented as you
thank you it's great to be here two
quick questions before we get to the
classified documents
um two people we've been talking about
in the show so far Prince Harry what is
your view of these two Harry and Megan
because apparently their approval
ratings plummeting Now in America
according to a Newsweek poll out today
well you know I always I use my 17 year
old daughter as a good barometer for
what she thinks of you know the
celebrity set
and I asked her I said Maria you know
what do you think you've been reading
all this stuff about Harry and Megan and
she my daughter said well Megan's really
pretty you know I like her clothes but
he seems like a real wuss
that's a 17 year old's opinion of what
is going on here and I think that kind
of sums it up for a lot of people I mean
it seems that the queen when she passed
on it brought back I think everything
that you know we love about tradition
and respect and Duty service to Country
service to nation and she really
epitomized that and that was such a
wonderful tribute and send off to her uh
almost an era gone by and he is kind of
representing almost 180 degree opposite
at least in this period I'm not talking
about when he was in the military or any
of that but in this period a lack of
gratitude a lack of concern for uh his
family I I I like the people who kind of
keep it inside the family explain to
your family can't complain within the
walls of the family otherwise lose the
title and don't completely agree if you
don't like it give up the titles and
just be the new Kardashians it's fine
um talking of keeping things inside
Madonna
New World Tour I have a view it's not a
very favorable view I think she's a
crinkly hot mess you'll take
well I'm glad you're bringing me on to
talk about the issues that I spend my
time focused on Cheers this is why I
love you you never know what you're
gonna get on this show okay well I I was
in college when Material Girl was the
big hit right so we'd be dancing the
fraternities the Dartmouth it was a
blast you know it was that era and it
was a fun kind of iconoclastic era well
I hate to break the news to Madonna but
that era is over yes there's no there's
no amount of kind of physical
transformation that's her that's her
business whatever she wants to do with
that but at some point like we all have
to kind of realize we're not 25 anymore
we're not 35 we're not 45. kind of act
your age have fun enjoy yourself but I
think everyone from from Tina Turner
Turner to uh you know Aretha Franklin
they understood how to how to progress
with age and be really cool and classy
you know you know Donna Summers like all
the great uh recording artists were able
to do that and and I think it's maybe a
little bit difficult for some people but
at some point it becomes a little bit
embarrassing I completely agree
let's get to why you thought you were on
Piers Morgan on censor tonight which is
the I like to jump in because you're so
good off the cuff anyway I could ask you
anything but this issue of the
classified documents two things about it
Leon Panetta to my surprise just now
said this let's play a little clip
it does detract from uh frankly uh you
know President Biden's effort to try to
uh say that uh what president Trump did
was wrong uh the fact is what he did is
not correct either so both are going to
have to face the consequences for the
way they mishandled classified documents
I've been interesting from Panetta there
I thought given that he worked our
course on the administration uh Biden
and Obama
um in a way I mean Biden's obviously
he's lost a moral ground on this it
might be more serious we don't know yet
what the consequences will be but a what
do you think about the implications for
him but also what does it mean for Trump
who was obviously very beleaguered on
this very issue but now perhaps not so
exposed
well a very interesting poll again it's
it's a snapshot we don't know exactly
what it means long term but an
interesting poll came out today by
morning consult it's a it's a fairly
well respected poll in the United States
and Trump and it was a Republican
primary poll and Trump's favorables I
believe were 50 which was the highest I
mean I'm talking about overall voters
um the highest they've been in quite a
long time and he trounces DeSantis by 17
points some other polls uh showed
DeSantis and Trump very close together
or even some cases DeSantis ahead of
trump so it might be that people are
beginning to see that you know all the
so-called controversies that people
think we got them this time we got them
this time that this is kind of another
one of those and uh that in in tough
times there's still a quite a hardcore
group of Republicans in the United
States who think that Trump is the only
guy to be able to take on the swamp he
knows where the bodies are buried now
and uh he he'll know how to hire people
uh right off the bat and maybe have his
priorities straight right off the bat
that's what I'm hearing from a lot of
people but it's way early I know that
sounds like a cop-out but it really is
it really is way early but I think on
this issue I'm half expecting you know
Biden to find you know some documents in
his dog's bed or something at this point
like who knows who knows you know that
dog that kept biting people it's back in
Wilmington dude I think the dog ate the
documents
it could go anywhere Laura thank you so
much for joining me I really appreciate
it uh the Lord I'm a big fan well I'm a
big fan that's a big fan of yours Mutual
big fast right back at you it's great to
have you on the show thank you very much
you're welcome